Ludwig and Tarik just hosted the final
official Valor event of the off season
and it was great we saw entertaining
matches some funny skits and it just
capped off a wild week in North America
in general so let's get into it
[Music]
all right before I get into things I
want to kindly ask that you like the
video subscribe to the channel and turn
on notifications I will personally
guarantee you a spot in franchising if
you do alright if you're a fan of North
American valorian then this past week
was a treat we had Challengers
qualifiers some above average Twitter
drama and some hype show matches you
could call it a normal week here in N A
to be honest but I think it's safe to
say that everyone is ready for the 2023
season to truly kick off Challengers
qualifiers definitely delivered we saw
some incredible matches from a lot of
top tier 2 talent and breakthrough
oxygen and dark ratio all managed to
qualify the sky's toasts roster also
made it into Challengers and it was nice
to see just how much passion he actually
has for the game and valerians as an
esport and clear is only able to get one
out of it
hands of Steel holding on to cats
pulling on from behind that out after
shocking now scuba in a 1v1 does he have
any idea that there's that there's a man
back yeah has no idea
now this is pretty much how I expected
things to go I correctly predicted three
out of the four teams in my pickum but
the Dr Pepper demon T-Dog had to [__]
take out Sonics and ruin my bracket and
then he decided to [__] all over them on
Twitter which I honestly found [__]
hilarious if you're watching this the
moment it goes up then the last chance
qualifier is already underway there are
still two spots up for grabs so I'll
definitely be keeping my eye on that but
I want to talk more about Twitter
because as the week went on so did the
drama on Thursday afternoon Sentinels
posted this video to Twitter
yo Tyson
yeah what is this thing isn't it obvious
it's a sharp Buck last year that's not
gonna work this year
but it works in Iceland
seems like a typical joke from Sentinels
to be honest they were just making fun
of themselves like they've had to for
the past year but Shazam wasn't too
happy about it Shaz replied to the tweet
and said quote Oh yeah one time I spun
the wheel and it landed on please play
with shroud or we don't care if you win
just make it hype we'll personally
guarantee you a spot in franchising if
you do end quote Sentinel CEO Rob Moore
then replied quote it's weird that since
you left all you talk about is how you
want to be with the organization when
for all of 2022 you behaved like you
didn't want to be here it seems like you
have returned to the focus you had in
2021 if so G2 will be in great hands end
quote Rob even began replying to other
comments suggesting that Shazam was
lying when he claimed that he found out
that he was off the team while live on
Twitch back in October Shaz then said
quote are you actually going to deny
promising me a spot if I did you this
huge favor don't lie to your players
best of luck to you and your new team
end quote to which Rob simply denied
making that promise now from the outside
looking in it's hard to say what goes on
behind the scenes at Sentinels but what
I can say is that after speaking with
Shazam many times over the past couple
years I don't find it that hard to
believe that he wasn't given the support
that he was asking for now sure I have
to speculate because I don't know what
goes on behind closed doors but I do
remember Shaz telling me that they
wanted a proper coach like Sean garez as
far back as 2021 early on like last year
in like August or September
um he was the one person I wanted as a
coach and like we're he's talking to the
org and like we're like he was down and
stuff but then the more we like start to
talk about details and stuff in our
practice schedule it just didn't work
out now back then Sean turning down that
offer makes complete sense he was still
casting events streaming and the dude
has a family this was well before he
coached hundred thieves don't get me
wrong I'm sure raucous helped and Danny
is my boy so I was happy to see them
join for part of last season but last
year psycho proved that he's the real
deal he helped make X at one of the best
teams in the entire world so I don't
blame Shazam for being upset when the
moment he's dropped from the team they
go out and sign a real Coach and
world-class players now once again I am
forced to speculate a bit here but
that's just my attention the one thing
that this argument did give us is a
fresh new meme format though
so after all this if any Valor fans
weren't hyped up enough Ludwig and tarek
hosted the final official Lan event of
the off season it was a summit style
event with casters and content creators
hanging out on couches and watching some
pretty solid teams compete for a 50 000
prize pool the matches went pretty much
how I expected if anything Sentinels
actually surprised me it looks pretty
good considering they only had about a
week of practice prior to the event I
was unsure how T1 would perform
considering they have a bunch of
Widowmaker Mains and my boy Sunny they
didn't look that great but I'll cut them
some slacks since their roster has gone
through a lot of changes too but the
true stars of the show were the two
Challengers seems not Ascension by the
way nobody has qualified for Ascension
and nobody will until sometime in July I
saw a lot of people calling the guard
and TSM Ascension teams so I just wanted
to clear that up anyways after getting
knocked down into the lower bracket TSM
took down T1 and won the rematch against
Sentinels I was happy to see that Haze
does continue to prove that he's a
fragging igl just like he was by the end
of last season now though I always
enjoyed watching seven frag out on doula
I think he actually played really well
in the Sentinel role but we gotta talk
about the Guard the guard are still
pretty nasty sure they lost side to T1
but Texas is a great player and it looks
like he's slotting in just fine but this
event simply reminded me just how [__]
cracked Trent and Jonah PR sure the
whole roster is disgusting but Trent and
Jonah are stars
[Music]
the reposition
oh
[Applause]
yeah they're kind of good at the video
game and Ludwig was loving it [__] your
franchise sees baby the tears the guard
won the grand finals and overall Ludwig
and tarek put on an incredible event it
had great Vibes amazing production and
funny skits with some awesome acting
from our friend treaty over at Riot but
this event was just another reminder
that everyone's excitement for Valor and
Esports hasn't gone anywhere this was
technically the last official event of
the off season but nearly 200 000 people
still showed up to watch partnered teams
compete against Challengers rosters and
with the lock-in tournament only one
month away I think it's safe to say that
everyone is ready for the 2023 season
well what did you think about the uh
sentinel's joke
I find it hilarious like I there's
people on the desk for the Ludwig terrac
event and like the guy would be in a
clutch and they'd be like oh if you if
you win this I'll personally guarantee
you a spot in franchising yeah
it's so good it's so good
I'm gonna say it in like my own mattress